in our real food series this morning
we're taking a look at the growing trend
of vertical farming the world's
population will climb around 7 billion
people to nearly 10 billion by 2050 that
will make it even more challenging to
feed everybody on the planet companies
like arrow farms are rethinking how we
grow the vegetables by going up to
provide fresh and affordable produce
Michelle Miller is at an arrow farms
indoor growing facility in Newark New
Jersey with the technology behind
vertical farming that's what it's called
Michelle good morning a good morning
well this is what vertical farming looks
like arugula kale watercress all growing
indoors on shelf stacks 7 levels high
it's all said and done arrow farm says
it can produce 1.7 million pounds of
greens every year this is to scale this
is what we mean by scale this 70
thousand square foot facility housed in
a former Newark steel plant this is 36
feet high is CEO David Rosenberg
green machine it produces 130 times more
produce than the average field form of
the same size in America per year but to
fully understand this large-scale
operation you got to go back to its
roots where it all began
seven years ago inside Phillips Academy
Charter School let me finish
arrow farms prototype was planted in the
school's cafeteria as a teaching tool
for students to learn the basics of
biology chemistry and nutrition
essentially these kids grow the greens
for their school salad bar I think
growing a food every day I seen it I
understand and have a better taste more
and better understanding for it you
appreciate it I appreciate a lot more
the technology is called aeroponics
which grows the plants on this reusable
fabric proprietary information also
called trade secrets but as savanah love
explained it to us this process needs no
soil no sunlight and uses less water
than conventional farming weird
CNET underneath so the water comes up to
the sheet and a hitch like the ceilings
hits them with a nutrient-rich solution
that allows the plant to take root these
LED lights substitute for the Sun this
was probably seated about three days ago
Rosenberg says vertical farming offers
higher yields with less land less time
and no pesticides they can farm indoors
in any city anywhere around the world
from seed to harvest in 16 days what
otherwise takes 30 days in the field and
then we're able to do that 22 times a
year versus in the field three times a
year because of seasonality still not
everyone is sold early adopting is not
necessarily bad Cornell University
researcher kale Harvick says his studies
found indoor farms that relies solely on
artificial light are not energy
efficient or sustainable just because
it's possible to grow inside a warehouse
doesn't mean it's a good idea doesn't
mean it's cost-effective if you do the
math the energy costs just aren't what
they should be Harvick warns these
companies struggle once their seed money
runs dry
case in point one Chicago based company
recently shut down its growing
operations these are our growing towers
Rosenberg says arrow farms LEDs that run
24/7 have been tweaked to save energy he
didn't share just how much
investors believe in it arrow farms has
raised over fifty million dollars from
the likes of Goldman Sachs and
Prudential and received more than nine
million dollars in state and local
grants why would someone want to buy
from you as opposed to a field farmer or
green house farmer here we're growing in
the local community that's the supply
chain difference but it turns out that
we're able to compete on taste and
texture by adjusting those lights and
nutrients Rosenberg says they can also
make their arugula more peppery their
kale a little sweeter which for many of
us parents in particular might be the
biggest selling point of all very
flavorful yes it is goodness and you
guys like your greens you really eat
them they really do and arrow farms has
also made a commitment to this community
about 45% of its employees are from the
Newark area to even sell these trays for
about 399 in local supermarkets here
Margaret what do you think market I'll
try it I'm vegetarian sign me up
I get excited that I'm thinking peppery
arugula there's not a bad thing wrong
with that nothing I see I see the other
side what they're saying but when you
look at all the pros and the cons the
pros seemed outweigh the cons to me on
that story worth the try michelle rhee
9q cool story there